Kirsten we are five months away from
Formula One racing right through the
strip eight months from the Super Bowl
taking over our town so much now today
an update on all the planning a news now
reporter Ryan Matthey joining us from
The Newsroom with the new progress
hey there are traffic headaches from
Formula One continue but are on track to
finish by October while planning for
Super Bowl game day operations are well
in motion with an emphasis on getting
the thousands of people in town around
we know it's disruptive we knew it would
be disruptive Terry Miller project
manager for the F1 track says work now
is focused on repaving off Las Vegas
Boulevard and finishing the paddock
building before a second and less
impactful round of repaving later this
summer we have made adjustments in
sequencing but we are still on schedule
as we had anticipated in terms of the
end of July for our first Paving
conclusion today was the first day we
kind of gave them a bigger picture of
everything that's happened over the past
year while Super Bowl host committee CEO
Sam Joffrey notes their engagement of
300 committee members 44 interns and
over 7 500 volunteers all from Las Vegas
on the drawing board now Transportation
has a federal 300 foot perimeter goes
into effect 48 hours before the game
posing obstacles for arriving Spectators
now take what's seen seemingly been
developed over the past year for Raiders
games or Taylor Swift concerts throw all
that out the window and figure out how
do we now get people in and out and back
and forth the stadium on Super Bowl in
February and he had there will be no
parking on the property itself meaning
those coming to the event will have to
be dropped off reporting in The Newsroom
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now